uh Gary Johnson the Libertarian
candidate had another what we are
describing and what he described as an
Aleppo moment you might remember that
couple weeks ago two three weeks ago he
was asked on MSNBC what would you do
about Aleppo and he said what is Aleppo
and it was not a good moment and he was
ridiculed for it he was on uh with uh
chris matthews on MSNBC a couple of days
ago he was asked to name his favorite
foreign leader or just any foreign
leader that he admires or just any
foreign leader whose name you can come
up with and it did not go well I'm gonna
play the video for you this is
cringe-worthy I'd get the kids out of
the room before watching this because it
could be disturbing who's your favorite
foreign leader who's my favorite and he
just name anywhere in the country any
one of the continents any country name
one foreign leader that you respect and
look up to anybody I was Shimon Peres
okay don't talk about living good you
got to do this any word any continent
Canada Mexico Europe over there gauges
South America Africa name a foreign
leader that you respect I guess I'm
having an Aleppo moment in the former
former president it makes whole world I
know I know anybody in the world you
like anybody pick any leader the former
president of mexico which one I'm come
having a brain I'm won a money box Saudi
ox see how the ocean favorite Friday get
him off the hook day before I lose
terrific any point leader um miracle
okay miracle okay fine save yourself
then are you a night anyway let's go
who's your favorite president in history
favor yeah so he just looks stunned and
Gary Johnson has this hilarious habit of
repeating a question in a way that makes
it sound insane right what did you have
for breakfast this morning what did I
have for breakfast this morning he can
take any question you ask and make it
sound like you're the crazy one by
repeating it with that tone of voice
some people reacted to this by saying oh
he looks crazy is just doesn't make any
sense uh there's many more reasons than
this for progressives not to vote for
Gary Johnson I mean the guy supports TPP
he supports fracking he opposes federal
policies that would make college more
affordable or reduce student debt
I know that there's this idea that Oh
Gary Johnson the libertarian is the
answer for Millennials not really uh but
did this this was not a good moment for
him really I love how most the pundits
out there are saying this could really
be a disqualifying move for him right
he's already been disqualified any news
polling less than ten percent not gonna
make it in the debates yeah if you if
you look at the polls it's pretty clear
that the American people have already
disqualified Gary Johnson not that is
funny though were like whoa whoa whoa
whoa now Gary Johnson's definitely not
going to win all right because he was in
this thing before the guy can't even
make it onto the debate stage this
reminded me of the sarah palin name
anything you read question from Katie
Couric from nearly eight years ago let's
just refresh our memories because it's
such a classic and when it comes to
establishing your worldview I was
curious what newspapers and magazines
did you regularly read before you were
tapped for this to stay informed and to
understand I room
to them again with a great appreciation
for the press for the media welcome mima
cific Lee I'm curious thank you um all
of them any of them that have been in
front of me over all these years i am
using i have a vast variety of sources
where we get our news to alaska isn't a
foreign country where it's kind of
suggested it seems like wow how could
you keep in touch with with the rest of
Washington DC maybe thinking and doing
when you live up there Alaska believe me
Alaska is like a microcosm oh yeah right
so not good not a good moment for Gary
Johnson I I kinda feel bad for him he
just seems to be a little bit is
absent-minded the right word or or I
don't know loses his train of thought or
something like that uh I do feel a
little bit bad for him but at the same
time he chose to run and he's accepting
these opportunities and you're going to
be asked questions we've gotta come up
with an answer uh yeah uh I I don't know
how many progressives were actually Curt
turned off by this because like I said
progressives should be acutely aware of
the reality that Gary Johnson is in
favor of a whole bunch of stuff that any
reasonable progressive should be against
and Gary Johnson is against a whole
bunch of stuff that any reasonable
reasonable progressive it should be in
favor of let me tell you what's on
today's bonus show hangover free alcohol
hangover free alcohol we will talk about
alco synth on the bonus show we will
talk about some lionesses that have
grown mains and have started to exhibit
certain traits of male lions which came
first in this one the chicken or the egg
I'll explain on the bonus show and also
automated strawberry picking is one step
closer to reality the fear as always how
many jobs will that destroy david
pakman.com slash membership that's the
number one way and really the only way
to sign up for membership and get access
to the bonus show we will take a break
and take phone calls next it is no
longer necessary to choose between price
and quality to get an amazing and
affordable shave Dollar Shave Club calm
is the answer
to prove how amazing their shave really
is right now they are going to give you
your first month free to join the club
Dollar Shave Club dot-com delivers great
razors right to my door for a third of
the price of what the greedy razor
corporations are charging if you know me
you know I can't stand dealing with
lines and crowded stores and I have no
reason to deal with that nor those
locked up razors that you need an
employee's permission to unlock at your
local store just go to Dollar Shave Club
dot-com and pick a razor that works for
you from their lineup of amazing blades
that's all there is to it I've been
pairing the executive blade with their
doctor Carver's shave butter the blade
glides for a super smooth shave and with
Dollar Shave Club you can look smell and
shave like a million bucks without
paying for it here's your chance to see
why over three million members like me
love Dollar Shave Club Dollar Shave Club
is so confident in the quality of all
their products now you can get your
first month of the club for free just
pay shipping after that just a few bucks
a month no long-term commitment
contracts or hidden fees there is no
reason not to do it get yours at Dollar
Shave Club dot-com / packman Dollar
Shave Club com / PA ke ma n